[Music]
hello my name is neha agrawal i'm a
clinical psychologist with the safe
harbor trauma recovery center at harbor
ucla thank you so much for coming to
this talk today
i i know i'm a little bit of an outlier
there's all these amazing
neuroscientists here and and really
distinguished researchers
and i'm a clinical psychologist so i i
do have a research background but i'm
mainly working
um
on the ground uh
really trying to take in the information
of what i see
happening with our clients in the
community as well as um
in in the hospital so
uh that's what's bringing me here today
and i'm going to talk to us about
what's been going on with our
rates of mental health distressed since
the kova 19 pandemic
and
kind of talk about what what some of the
numbers look like
and also
some thoughts about future directions
and and how to maybe address this rising
distress
so as i said um my learning objectives
will be to provide current statistics on
mental health disorders related to the
coven 19 pandemic
and then i really want to contextualize
depression anxiety and post-traumatic
stress disorder from a loss framework
about really you know the losses that
were specific to
um being in a global pandemic
and then also introduce a
socio-ecological perspective to recovery
and well-being so looking beyond the
individual to address this increase in
distress right now and then just close
with a mindfulness activity to
really experi to provide that
experiential piece of how do we
reclaim our vitality
so the inspiration of this
um i guess title was
a quote from a book called the noonday
demon by andrew solomon it's a really
beautiful book on depression um about
very about his personal experience as
well as
um current interventions and research
and it's just a really wonderful
um overview but this just stood out to
me right that the opposite of depression
is not happiness but vitality
so i think we're at this point we know
that happiness might not be the goal
but i i think sometimes you know we
still have that craving
and really how do we
incorporate vitality as
as the as a benchmark how do we
re-energize our
purpose how do we feel this zest for
life
um and want to approach it rather than
retreat from it which is usually what
depression and trauma and anxiety
um
contribute to the psyche is is the
retreat from life not the approach
and so that's that's the concept i think
of when i'm thinking broadly and for my
clients for myself for my family for my
friends is how do we re-energize
ourselves about
life
and
given just the
incredible loss that we've experienced
in the last two years
um
you know i don't even have the current
number
of the deaths but loss is so much more
than death
there has been a questioning of
meaning of life um and and not even just
with covid but everything else
sociopolitically that's happening
we're questioning what is oh you know
what is our purpose in life and
i think i want us to just sit in that
framework of vitality as
a
antidote um
not happiness or contentment because you
know that wouldn't be fair given
everything that's going on
so i'll um just start you know i found
this very interesting that um you know
colloquially we're all talking about
uh the rise in mental health distress
and the rise in mental health disorders
and and for sure anecdotally i work at a
community hospital in
the south bay um in los angeles county
and
you know it feels like we've been
just flooded i work specifically at a
trauma recovery center and people
are consistently
being referred um
it and and the other place i work is an
intensive outpatient for young adults
and adolescents and and we're also
packed so it really feels like when
doing the work that the rates are really
really high
and so when i was looking up some of the
stats it was interesting to see that um
the stats in in the early stages of the
pandemic so people collecting just like
prevalence in 2020 um were pretty high
right so they did some um studies
systematic reviews
for prevalence of anxiety depression
post-traumatic stress psychological
distress and stress and again for
anxiety at rates as high as 50
like 60
depression 48
post ptsd 53
uh percent psychological distress 38 and
of course stress
about 81 so
self-report the reviews were showing
like okay there's a lot of distress here
right now
um
and of course risk factors were in in
this review at least were female gender
younger age
of course people with chronic or
psychiatric illnesses unemployment
student status and frequent exposure to
um the news around
um covert 19.
so this was pretty uh consistent with
what i was finding in what like these
early stages
um
and what i was finding for the recent
statistics which is i'm not going to
call it the later stage because honestly
are we out are we not that those are
still questions up in the air but i'm
going to call the current stage of our
pandemic um
that
actually looking at some of the reviews
and data collected in 2021 longitudinal
follow-up studies
concluded that rates of depression and
anxiety and ptsd and distress were
lowered and um people that were studying
resilience noticed just how how strong
resiliency factors were
um
and again the risk factors
do remain to be like child adolescent
student mental health and and front line
health care workers are at greater risk
of increased distress but overall
this is what the data was showing for
2021 and and even there was a stat about
people with um
psychiatric diagnoses prior to
uh covid were at the same level it's not
that it was increased in some way
so i i found that very interesting
because we're talking about it and i
think yes the youth mental health crisis
is is very real and there is a general
national or global mental health crisis
and how much that's related to covid is
interesting um to think about because
actually
it seems like some of these studies are
pointing to how this pandemic has
increased resilience in people
the only thing here though is that the
limitations of these studies
were that there wasn't a personalized
approach the self-report measures of
course may not have accurately captured
the level and quality of distress
and
you know i think we're looking at a
different type of distress right now
right it's not straightforward
depression it's not straight for anxiety
it's not straightforward ptsd and i'll
go into that in a second
um and i think
you know given where we are at currently
i don't know if it's fair
to say that we're in the post-trauma
that we're in a post-traumatic or
post-pandemic world right now um ongoing
research is going is necessary to
understand whether symptoms or
functioning or well-being
increase how it fluctuates and then what
does a remission look like um i think
we're in a kind of a new
and somewhat exciting and so it's weird
to say that word but way to really how
are we conceptualizing people's
diagnoses people's well-being and and
how are we conceptualizing suffering
right now
so um i really drew upon um
markowitz's work on
he is a researcher and developer of
interpersonal psychotherapy ipt for
depression anxiety and ptsd and he wrote
something about
how to use these therapies
in the context of a global pandemic
and he has this great
chart i think that really allows us to
see
these
symptoms of anxiety
ptsd and depression
from a framework of loss and and
specific
threats that were um
highlighted during uh the coven 19
pandemic so
you know he talks about the loss of
security loss of income loss of
employment loss of loved ones loss of
routine loss of social support right
these are all losses that
pandemic aside would impact um
one's mental health and well-being
and and in the next column he writes
that um
what the threats are specifically
for
these losses that would then result in
some of these manifestations of anxiety
pain ptsd depression and anxiety
so
uh for example the loss of security the
it's in in this context is a potential
lethal viral of an infection and
especially at these beginning stages not
knowing anything about
the spread who is at risk um what is a
vaccine you know we're living in a world
now where
um we've found solutions thanks to like
the really incredible ingenuity of human
beings um
but at that
and still currently we're we're looking
at what is what how is this going to
develop
and then of course our security of the
people that are
keeping us safe and healthy are also so
vulnerable
both physically and psychologically
and
that idea of like our our leaders our
health care leaders are vulnerable and
might we might not have access to them
that of course leads to a fear
of the illness and a fear of security
and being um having our safety nets
for our health
loss of income
i mean the amount of folks that i saw
that came in that were referred to us
for some interpersonal
violence really were the distress was
about what they're going to do during
covid um not having rent not having food
to feed their families um
kind of and then not having the options
to go places to the normal ways they
would get food in the community
and so really
fear of that loss of income and again
like maslow's hierarchy that basic
safety
and that inter that anxiety about how
you're going to get it and then the
depression of
something must be wrong with me i can't
do this or that that helplessness that
comes along with not being able to
support yourself or your families
loss of employment
damage to career and income
i have to say that working with folks
that had just um entered the job force
there was a huge demoralization of
what like how what does work look like
um
of course you know just the the
self-efficacy of making money for yours
it's all
you know it all crumbled at that time
and again that anxiety about how will i
uh achieve my
my standard of living and also the
depression of am i capable of it
um loss of loved ones this complicated
morning piece this is going to be a huge
one and i think there are a lot of
studies about
our disrupted morning rituals i mean
again the resiliency of humans of
finding ways to come together to mourn
was um incredible to see and to witness
and be part of
but there was so much disrupted mourning
and humans
are about social mourning that is that
is something that is across cultures
and
um
even now for people that were lost
before how are people
coming and now when it's safer to gather
back to revisit that grief and
you know there's that that saying that
grief doesn't shrink but we grow around
our grief
and
that right now the grief is is pretty
ever present
um loss of routine
this is really big especially for
psychiatric disorders
for mood disorders specifically
the disrupted social rhythms
have really impacted
how
you know how people regulate their mood
right motivation as we know is not
enough um being the right mood is not
enough so social rhythms and routine is
very very important for people that are
suffering from
more of the major
psychiatric disorders
and
and of course the loss of social support
physical distance can mean social
isolation and social isolation
results in anxiety and depression you
know i think we're all living in an era
of zoom fatigue
and
that really helped for a lot of people
and also just that physical closeness
and connection
what is something that again is part of
our need as humans
further
you know so
people that weren't just isolated from
others but in an unsafe environment
themselves
thinking of
survivors of domestic violence or
children who who had
neglectful or abusive parents
there is
not just socially isolated but they're
they're kind of immersed into their
dangerous um environment
so
you know and i just want to talk about
privilege here and i'll get to that
slide like a lot of these things you
know in
i
experienced these things and also had a
lot of privilege to to buffer from
some of the um suffering
that comes from
these loss of income complicated morning
home lockdown i was able to see
friends um
you know my my job was relatively stable
and
a lot you know so so in some ways i
built a resiliency
that
you know came with some privilege but
when we look at our social determinants
of health
these things are exacerbated
based on the social context we're in
so that's sort of
the next slide bowden and all
really talked about
the social determinants of health and
social risk factors
and the interaction of pandemic
stressors so
if you're living in i mean we are living
in a context of
um institutional racism
and
income inequality
and
these uh factors around our identity
have over and over predicted what our
health outcomes are so
that
interacting with
already vulnerable
populations for mental health
with all those stressors i just um
discussed in the previous slide
it's going to have negative mental
health outcomes that maybe aren't
remitting as fast as some of those
longitudinal studies might have shown
so that's just something to keep in mind
is how and who are we looking at
when we're
looking at the impact of
negative mental health outcomes
so i'm going to do a
transition because
i think this is just a very key point to
to hold and for researchers to think
about how are we measuring
mental health distress in what
population
and in what context those things are are
very important to keep in mind
um but i do want to talk about uh
go to the next phase of what what are we
going to do how are we going to address
these rates and and even if they seem to
be
lowering
how are we going to continue to use this
experience as a way to bolster how we
look
at
psychological
and mental well-being and emotional
well-being
um and i really liked this article by
zhang at all
um looking at cultivating resilience in
in the aftermath of the pandemic and
again i say aftermath and with an
asterisk or quotes
um
you know the study was done in china but
i other papers have really been looking
at this has been highlighting that
working on the individual level is just
not enough
the individual level is very important
but if we do not have the systems and
culture and institutions
to support
in bolstering um
what well-being you know things will
crumble
and you know our health care system and
definitely our mental health
care system
noticed that um in those in that first
year
so on the individual level the
engagement in health protective
behaviors so you know they were really
talking about
coming back to this mind and body right
we're we're not when we're looking at
our approach to distress it's not just
about our thoughts
um
there is some real we have to take care
of our bodies and
they talked about health protective
behaviors within the context of
capability opportunity and motivation so
how do we
allow for health protective behaviors
for example
places where there was
hand sanitizer everywhere regular
ppe and encouraging people to take care
of their bodies
and how that mind-body connection is
ever present right that they're not
we're not dual they're not separated so
really taking in
you know on the individual level
how are we taking care of our health and
therefore our mental health at the same
time and vice versa of course
cognitive and emotional resilience so i
know resilience can sometimes be a vague
term but
you know
i think in some of the second wave
behavioral
approaches there's this idea that if we
change our thoughts we can change our
mood and
um
and we need to change certain emotions
but cognitive emotional resilience is
really speaking of
i can tolerate uncertainty and i can i
my emotions are not to be feared but
they're they are informative to me
they um whatever i'm experiencing
is part of understanding myself in this
context of uncertainty so resilience is
again not about
saying
everything is better or again you're
happy but it's about knowing that you
can withstand
difficult thoughts and difficult
emotions and maybe even come out
stronger for it
so really building that capacity again
with um
with some of the amazing
behavioral uh tools that we have and and
from
cognitive behavioral therapies
dialectical behavior therapy acceptance
and commitment therapy all these
wonderful evidence-based therapies
and having those more widely available
to to people
i think that's something that was also
highlighted is
quality mental health care as well
so that's on the individual level on the
organizational level enhancing
organizational support so
this was really talking about basic
things like having the proper ppe
having um
you know
leave time having the structure in place
for
employees to be able to take mental
health days
taking those initiatives to help
maintain their emotional well-being so i
can see these in some of the
you know larger tech companies or
really giving their employees
opportunities
but again how does that trickle down
into our
um
you know our um
our workers that don't have some of
those
um
you know benefits in place
and this is very important in kind of
buffering
um some of that helplessness that it's
me i must if i
am not getting through this there must
be something wrong with me but really
that you know if you're working so hard
if you're pushing
up this rock
against a mountain you are
um
you're it's setting someone up to fail
and this was interesting too providing
timely support for employees career
development i think you know we're
seeing a at least in the u.s a lot of
people leaving the workforce
and um which is you know going to impact
the individual the economy a lot of
things and how are organizations
really
providing people with opportunities to
grow opportunities to
take different roles in their jobs to be
leaders
again that sense of vitality of like yes
this isn't easy and maybe not
we're not happy but how are we gonna
take care how am i gonna see you as
someone that's growing within this
organization whatever
that ceiling might be but just at least
putting that on the table
that there is a development in your work
life in your
in your um
in the in the work or or
um roles that you play in your life
and uh and then the community and
national level right so
really
really looking at community mental
health as community mental health right
community mental health isn't okay we're
gonna drop these therapists into a
community and they'll talk individually
community mental health is how do we
build the
connection amongst folks in their
community how do we get peers involved
people from the community to
strengthen those trust um
so the social capital of communities is
really like how do folks in their
communities trust their
um
their leaders really
sorry not their leaders but that trust
each other in it and so what types of
initiatives uh what kind of block
parties what sort of
um
ways are you bringing
people out together to build that social
capital music festivals arts festivals
all these things increase vitality
um
and that builds that trust enhance
solidarity
and
meaning making it really you know big
part of resilience is how we're making
meaning of all of this so the example i
like i said for our
mental health institutions and mental
health care given all of this distress
the meaning making for me
is
what are we learning from this how are
we honing into this and how for the
first time are we really thinking beyond
the individual
i think that that's a very exciting
place for me to be in as a person that's
more early in their career
and then as a nationally
of course supporting pro-social ventures
and addressing mental health and health
inequality through
policy and funding
so um i'm going to
uh take a minute to to close with a
mindfulness exercise to really embody
this sense of vitality and
not just our current vitality but
reclaiming this energy and zest
um
for life and well-being and connection
um if you have a piece of paper like a
white piece of paper like this
or or any line piece of paper i'd like
you to just bring it out and fold it in
half and have stuff in it um
or uh just any anything you can write
with or that you have in front of you
you can do that and if not i'm gonna
actually put a white screen up so uh we
can do this exercise from this like more
empty and blank space i just wanted to
provide the text though in case
and
so i'll begin
as you're either staring
at this piece of paper or this white
slide in front of you
just want to begin by taking some
mindful breaths
arriving in this moment
feeling grounded to the surface below
you
and alert yet relaxed in your posture
start to notice cool air on the inhale
and warm breath on the exhale as we
engage
in this activity together
i would like you to rest your gaze on
that blank piece of paper or the slide
in front of you
and for a moment
just rest your gaze there
and notice any thoughts or judgments or
emotions that may be arising
as you gaze upon this blank piece of
paper
or slide
i invite you to imagine a time where you
felt unrestricted
perhaps center your awareness around a
time in your life prior to march 2020
see if you can bring your awareness to
something that you have been restrained
from doing
in these last two years
or perhaps something you have done a lot
less of during this time
see if you can visualize
on this blank screen or paper a specific
time in which you were engaging in that
activity
or feeling of being
unrestricted and even free
vital
try to position yourself with specific
details
see if you can imagine your physical
surroundings
who you are with
what time of day it was
the expression on your face
what you may have been smelling hearing
feeling
tasting
imagine that scene playing out in front
of you
on this blank page
if it is difficult to imagine this that
is okay
just bring your awareness back to your
breath
notice any thoughts
sensations or emotions and judgments
that may be arising while doing this
and just non-judgmentally
bring yourself back
to this moment
and maybe in your own time
or take some time after this talk i
would like you to take that piece of
paper
in front of you
and draw depict or express without words
that scene that you had imagined
let yourself feel unrestricted
in how you express this
and then after doing this i invite you
to just think of one word that that
scene represents
and write it inside
and then carry that with you and see how
you incorporate that value
into
[Music]
things you could do now or are doing now
again just notice
what's coming up for you in this moment
hopefully some of you are doing this
activity on your own or maybe some of
you are just thinking about it
and just give yourself a nod of
gratitude
and compassion
for being able to
allow yourself
to immerse in that sense of freedom and
on restriction
thank you very much
here are my
references
and
i
please reach out if there are any
questions
you